لا
اله
الا
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لله
الله اكبر الله
اه ا
[Silence]
اكبر
اله
و
احز لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد
الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا كث
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
لله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا اله الا
الله وحده سك
وعده ونصر
عبده وهز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا محمد
على اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا كثيرا
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره واصيلا
لا اله الا
الله وحده صدق صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا يعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
আসসালামু আলাইকুম ওরাহমাতুল্লাহি
ওয়াবারাকাতুহলাকুমলাম back up
‏more
minut
before we have the crit in the back and
boilable so pleas make 12 person for me
in your house and this
‏haveademy
strew so pleas make you
haveerademy andar
‏are
some
anybody may not may be
interesting
to more
المقصود السلام علیکم و رحمه الله
وبرکاته برادران و خواهران عزیز برادر ما
فرمود که اینجا اکمی رحمه داریم برای
اطفال که درس دین یاد بگیرن اینجا کسی اگر
دلچسپی داشته باشه میتانه که اطفال خود
بیاره اینجا راجستر کن اینجا درس دینی را
یاد بگیر بگیرن و همچنان ب تحصیلی دارن
کسی میخواه از او بورسیه مستفید شوه
همچنان میتانند ازاب برسی نام کنن و دیگه
یک چند دقیقه دیگه هم وقت میگیریم تکبیرات
ادامه میتیم بعد از یک چند پ دقیقه دیگه
انشاالله نماز عی ره شروع میکنیم بخیر
همین را خواستیم براتان فارسی ترجمه کنیم
جزاکم الله خیر الله اکبر
الله اکبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا اله الا
الله وحده صدق
وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده
هزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا اله الا الله
ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
سيدنا
محمد وعلى اصحاب
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
محمد وسلم
تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد ما دي برذرز ان سيسترز السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته ان شاء
الله
ان امام ابو حنيفه رحمه الله
تعالى
تكبيرات
ركعه
ركعه تكبيره
الاحرام
تكبيره تكبيره
سوره
الفاتحه
تكبيره
ركعه
سجود
تكبيره
الفاتحه
سوره تكبيرات
تكبي
تكبيره
تكبيره ركوع ان شاء
الله سكن ركعه
برادران وخواهران السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته شيخ
تاریخ النماذ به قول امام ابو حنیفه رحمت
الله علیه رحمت الله علیه فرمودن قسم ما
ادا میکنیم نماز عید سید الفطره رکعت اول
نیت نیت میکنیم الله اکبر که گفتیم بعدا
سه تکبیر میکنیم که دستاتانرا بالا میکنین
سه تکبیر که ادا کردین بعد از او شیخ صاحب
تلاوت الحمد شریف با یک سوره قرآن پاک
تلاوت می‌کنه بعدم میریم به رکوع و بعدم
به سجود در رکعت دوم برعکس میباشد اول
الحمد شریف تلاوت میشه با یک سوره قرآن
پاک بعد باز سه تکبیرات هسته با تکبیرات
دستهای خودرا با گوش خود بالا میکنین سه
تکبیر که تکمیل شد در در تکبیر چهارم شما
میرین به رکوع بعدم به سجود این هم میشه
تکمیل نماز عید سیدالفطر
انشاءالله
بالعربي
سنصلي متبعين مذهب الامام ابی ابي حنيفه
النعمان رحمه الله
تعالى التكبيرات ستبدا بتكبيره
الاحرام مع رفع اليد ثم نكبر ثلاث تكبيرات
زوائد ثم اقرا سوره الفاتحه وسوره معها
ثم بعد ذلك
اكبر للركوع في الركعه الثانيه سابدا
بقراءه سوره الفاتحه وسوره معها وابدا
بثلاث تكبيرات
زوائد وثم اكبر التكبيره الرابعه واذهب
الى الركوع ثم نكمل الركعه الثانيه بهذه
الطريقه كامله
استووا استقيموا الى الصلاه يرحمكم الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقم
قيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
هل اتاك حديث
الغاشيه
وجوه يومئذ
خاشعه
عامله
ناصبه تصلى نارا
حاميه تسقى
من عين
انيه ليس لهم طعام الا من
ضريع لا يسمن ولا يغني من
جوع
وجوه
يومئذ ناعمه
لسعيها
راضيه في
جنه
عاليه لا تسمع فيها
لاغيه فيها
عين
جاريه فيها
سرر
مرفوعه واكو
ابواب
موضوعه
ونمارق
مصفوفه
وزرابي
مبثوثه افلا
ينظرون الى الابل كيف
خلقت والى
السماء كيف
رفعت والى الجبال كيف
نصبت والى الارض كيف
سطحت
فذكر
انما انت
مذكر لست
عليهم
بمسيطر الا من
تولى
وكفر
فيعذبه الله العذاب
الاكبر ان
الينا
ايابهم ثم ان
علينا
حسابهم الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والفجر
وليال
عشر والشفع
والوتر والليل اذا
يسر هل في ذلك قسم لذي
حجر الم تر كيف فعل ربك
بعاد ارم ذات العما
ماد التي لم يخلق مثلها في
البلاد وثمود الذين جابوا الصخر
بالواد وفرعون ذي
الاوتاد الذين طغوا في البلاد
لاد فاكثروا فيها
الفساد فصب عليهم ربك سوط
عذاب ان ربك
لبالمرصاد فاما
الانسان اذا ما ابتلاه ربه
فاكرمه
ونعمه فيقول
ربي
اكرما
واما اذا ما ابتلاه فقدر عليه
رزقه فيقول
ربي
اهان كلا
بل لا
تكرمون
اليتيم ولا
تحاضون على طعام
المسكين
وتاكلون التراث اكلا
لما
وتحبون المال حبا
جما
كلا اذا دكت الارض
دكا
وجاء ربك
والملك صفا
صفا
وجيء يومئذ
بجهنم
يومئذ
يتذكر
الانسان
وانا له
الذكرى يقول يا
ليتني قدمت
لحياتي
فيومئذ لا يعذب عذابه
احد ولا يوثق
وثاقه
احد يا
ايتها النفس
المطمئنه
ارجعي الى ربك
راضيه
مرضيه فادخلي ادخلي في
عبادي
وادخلي
جنتي
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اله
الا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله
الحمد
لله حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا حمدا يليق بجلال
وجهه وكمال
صفاته وعظيم سلطانه
يا
ربنا لا نحصي ثناء عليك انت كما اثنيت على
نفسك واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له له الملك وله الحمد يحيي
ويميت وهو على كل شيء
قدير واشهد ان سيدنا وحبيبنا
وشفيعنا
ونبينا محمدا عبده
ورسوله وصفيه
وخليله بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه ونصح
الامه وكشف الغمه تركنا على المحجه
البيضاء ليلها
كنهارها لا يزيغ عنها الا
هالك صلى الله عليه وعلى اله
الطيبين واصحابه
اجمعين ومن سار على
نهجهم الى يوم الدين رضوان الله تبارك
وتعالى علينا وعليهم
اجمعين فيا عباد الله اوصيكم ونفسي اولا
بتقوى الله تعالى
وطاعته ولزوم اوامره وكثره
مخافته اطيعوا الله والرسول لعلكم ترحمون
ايها
المؤمنون فقد قال الله سبحانه
وتعالى في محكم
التنزيل يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا
الله وقولوا
قولا
سديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم ومن يطع الله
ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما تقوى
[Silence]
الله ايها المسلمون
ودعنا ضيفنا
العزيز ضيفنا
الكريم ودعنا
سريعا شهر رمضان
المبارك
وكان
ضيفا
خفيفا مباركا
كريما نسال الله
تعالى ان يتقبل
صيامنا
وصلاتنا
ونفقاتنا وان يعتق
رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا من
النار رمضان
[Silence]
الله عن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه عن النبي
صلى صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه وسلم
قال كل
حسنه يعملها ابن ادم فله عشر
امثالها الا
الصيام الا
الصيام فانه لي وانا اجزي به وازد ابو
هريره
صلى الله عليه
وسلم الله سبحانه
وتعالى انذا حديث القدسي
[Silence]
ايها
المسلمون لقد قد صمتم
رمضان
واستجبتم لطاعه
الرحمن واقمتم
لياليه لتحصلوا على رضا الرب عز
وجل
ومغفرته
ورضوانه والعتق من
النيران جئتكم اليوم الى
مصلاكم جئت جئتم اليوم الى
مصلاكم تكبرون الله تعالى على ما هداكم
اليه من دين قوي وصراط
مستقيم موحدين الله موحدين الله
تعالى وقد خرجتم الى صلاه العيد وقلوبكم
قد امتلات به فرحا
وسرورا تسالون الله
تعالى الرضا
والقبول روي عن سيدنا امير المؤمنين علي
بن ابي طالب كرم الله وجهه ورضي الله عنه
انه كان ينادي في اخر ليله من
رمضان يا ليت شعري من هذا
المقبول
فنهنيه ومن هذا
محروم
فنعزيه
فاليوم
فاليوم اسم هذا اليوم في
السماء يوم
الجائزه سمضان
[Silence]
الله
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏name يوم
الجائزه سنه النبي صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
ملائكه عليهم
السلام وقد جاء في
الاثر ان يوم
العيد يوم عيد الفطر
المبارك يسمى يوم
الجوائز واهم هذه
الجوائز واغلاها ثمنا واعلاها
قدرا عفو الله تعالى ومغفره الذنوب والعتق
من النيران والفوز زي برضوان الله عز وجل
والدخول الى الجنه فكيف اذا يكون
المجازي هو الله
تعالى ايها
المسلمون
العيد
فرصه لكل
مسلم ليتطهر من درن
الاخطاء فلا يبقى في
قلبه الا بياض
الالفه ونور
الايمان تتصافى القلوب وتتصافح
الايدي ويتبادل الجميع التهاني
[Silence]
فسارعوا ايها الاخوه سارعوا الى اصلاح ذات
بينكم
وكونوا عونا لانفسكم
واخوانكم على الشيطان ولا تكونوا عونا
للشيطان على اخوانكم
[Silence]
عيد
سلام
[Silence]
اف ولا تقل لهما
ارحم
[Silence]
وا
قران ومن اياته ان خلق لكم من انفسكم
ازواجا لتسكنوا اليها وجعل بينكم موده
ورحمه
[Silence]
التوحيد حضره النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم عليه الصلاه
والسلام
القران السنه
الله سبحانه
وتعالى اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله العظيم
لي ولكم ولوالدي ولسائر المسلمين اجمعين
ويا فوز
المستغفرين استغفروا
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا لا اله الا الله وحده صدق وعده
ونصر عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار سيدنا
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا
كثيرا اللهم يا حنان ويا
منان ويا ديان ويا
مستعان يا قديم الفضل والاحسان يا
الله نسالك اللهم والامان الامان من زوال
الايمان والعفو عما مضى منا
وكان من الذنوب والزلل والخطايا والتقصير
والعصيان الوداع يا شهر
رمضان الوداع يا شهر
القران الوداع
يا شهر القيام والتراويح
والتسابيح الوداع يا شهر النفقات
والصدقات الوداع يا شهر
الفقراء
والمساكين
اللهم اعد علينا
رمضان اعواما
عديده وايا
اياما
مديده وازمله
مديده اللهم كما بلغتنا شهر
الصيام فاجعل عامه علينا من ابرك الاعوام
وايامه من اسعد
الايام وتقبل اللهم ما قدمناه من الصيام
والقيام يوم لا يرجى فيه سواك يا عليم ويا
يا
علام اللهم اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا من النار اللهم فرج عن اخواننا
المستضعفين في كل مكان
اللهم انصر اخواننا في
فلسطين وارحم شهدائهم يا رب العالمين
اللهم اشف
جرحاهم
اللهم اونا
نازحيهم اللهم من اراد المسلمين بسوء
فاجعل
دائره السوء تدور
عليه سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون وسلام
على
المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
الله اكبر
الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
[Silence]
اله الا
الله
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهز زم
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا الله
ولا
نعبد اياه
مخلصين له
الدين ولو كر
اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم تسليم
كثيرا
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر الا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر ولله
لله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الا
والله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر كبيرا
والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وحزم
الاحزاب وحده
لا
اله الا
الله
ولابد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى ذريه
سيدنا
محمد وعلى انصار
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا كثي
الله اكبر
الله السلام
عليكم السلام
‏pleas up for people com
and so upate
ইনশল্লাহ
ডুংসার কাতুল ফিত 12
personন মিথ
‏up any not pleas make tak care boxes
also you have youay pleas make that is
before the starts delay that little
because of the tric coming in so just
bear with us and stay with the insall
for next 10 minut also one otherinder
when
we academy in our
প্রম
ডer
পজিট 75
লারশিপ মসজিদ
এনশল্লাহ অস ম্যজার মাম
হাসান
আহাব
আল্লাহু আকবার
আল্লাহু
আকবার الا
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد
الا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا اله الا
الله نعبد ولا نعبد الا اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره الكافرون
اللهم صل على
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ال
محمد وعلى اصحاب سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ذريه
محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا
محمد وسلم تسليما كثيرا
كثيرا مازر
تكبيرات بروت محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
زينوا اعيادكم
بالتكبير اوكي ميك يور عيدف تكبير
اوكي
الله اكبر
الا
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اله الا
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
ولله الحمد
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
الله
والله اكبر
الله اكبر
ولله الحمد الله اكبر
كبيرا والحمد الحمد لله
كثيرا
وسبحان الله بكره
واصيلا
اله الا
الله وحده صدق وعده ونصر
عبده واعز جنده وهزم
الاحزاب وحده لا
اله الا
الله ولا نعبد الا
اياه مخلصين له
الدين ولو كره
الكافرون اللهم صل على
سيدنا محمد وعلى ال سيدنا محمد
وعلى اصحاب
سيدنا
محمد وعلى ازواج
محمد وعلى انصار
سيدنا
محمد وسلم
تسليما
كثيرا كثيرا
‏sister sister